our top story tonight concerns the
internet aka the electronic cat database
but first let's take just a moment
together and appreciate how amazing the
internet is you can use it to file your
taxes apply for jobs you can go online
right now and buy a case of coyote urine
do you know how difficult it used to be
to obtain coyote on you literally had to
give a coyote Gatorade and just wait it
was a mess the system was a mess but but
if you've turned on the news lately you
may have heard some worrying references
to the Internet
changing the Federal Communications
Commission is agreed to move forward on
a proposal it could change the way we
use the Internet at risk the basic
principle of net neutrality net
neutrality is Rowdy yes
net neutrality the only two words that
promise more boredom in the English
language are featuring sting pairing
people talk about it is somehow even
worse as anticipated that notice
proposes to ground the net neutrality
rules in Section 706 of the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 oh my god
that is the most boring thing I've ever
seen that is even boring by c-span
standards I would rather read a book by
Thomas Friedman than sit through that
hearing I would rather listen to a pair
of Dockers tell me about the weird dream
it had I would rather sit down with my
niece and watch car you a children's
show about a bald Canadian child who
lives a life devoid of any incident boo
Caillou
and leave the house find out what the
worlds are boots come on but here's the
thing
net neutrality is actually hugely
important essentially it means that all
data has to be treated equally no matter
who creates it it's why the Internet is
a weirdly level playing field and
startups can supplant established brands
that's how Facebook supplanted MySpace
which supplanted Friendster which
supplanted actually having any friends
do you remember physically having
friends it was awful
you couldn't tap people's faces to make
them go away but the point is the
Internet in its current form is not
broken and the FCC is currently taking
steps to fix that the FCC is endorsing
new rules that could clear the way for
it to tear system the rules would open
the door for the first time for internet
providers like Comcast and Verizon to
charge tech companies to send content to
consumers more quickly Netflix for
example might pay a premium to ensure
that its customers can stream movies
more reliably at a cost a start-up
competitor might not be able to afford
no this cannot happen how else is my
startup streaming video service nut
flicks going to compete it's going to be
America's one-stop resource for videos
of men getting hit in the nuts you don't
even know you want it yet that's why
it's brilliant ending net neutrality
would allow big companies to buy their
way into the fast lane leaving everyone
else in the slow lane
although telecom companies would prefer
that you put it in a slightly different
way when you say fast lane in slow lane
it's a good illustration but what you
really should be talking about is a fast
lane for everybody and a hyperspeed lane
for others
if we let cable companies offer to speed
of service they won't be Usain Bolt and
Usain Bolt
on a motorbike they'll be Usain Bolt and
Usain Bolt egde to an anchor and telecom
companies will say they would never slow
down a website speed in order to get
more money out of them but but let me
tell you a little story recently Comcast
was negotiating with Netflix
this graph shows Netflix download speeds
on various providers that black line
plummeting downwards was their speed on
Comcast during the negotiation see if
you can guess when Netflix agreed to
Comcast demands I'll give you a hint
it's right there that has all the
ingredients of a mob shakedown Netflix
does show about life in a ladies prison
such a shame if there was going to be
something happen to your connection area
so frustrating that would be
it's not just anti corporate hippies who
think that abandoning net neutrality is
a bad idea the net neutrality movement
is leery of big corporate players but in
this debate it's on the same side as
some of them Google Facebook Netflix
Amazon all signed onto this letter
supporting net neutrality what's being
proposed is so egregious activists and
corporations have been forced onto the
same side that's basically Lex Luthor
knocking on Superman's Apartment door
and going listen I know we have our
differences but we have got to get rid
of that in apartment 3b he's
he's too loud soup he's just too loud
and you might wonder well look if
everyone is against this how is it even
possibly happening or consider who would
benefit from this change cable companies
Verizon wants a two-tier system so badly
they sued the government to force the
rule change that's currently being
discussed these companies have
Washington in their pockets to a
conveniently almost unbelievable degree
comcast has spent 18 million eight
hundred ten thousand dollars in lobbying
last year it's more than any other
company for defense contractor north of
chromatin so just to be clear the
ranking of who boys government influence
is number one military-industrial
complex and number two the provider of
Lizard Lick towing I could show you the
troublingly cozy relationship between
cable companies in Washington in any
number of ways I could show you the
president golfing with the CEO of
Comcast or saying at a fundraiser at a
cable executives house that he'd been
there so many times the only thing I
haven't done in this house is have Seder
dinner but but perhaps the most succeed
way is this the president has picked Tom
wheeler a former top lobbyist for cable
and wireless companies to be the next
chair of the Federal Communications
Commission yes the guy who used to run
the cable industry's lobbying arm is now
running the agency tasked with
regulating it that is the equivalent of
needing a babysitter and hiring a dingo
here thanks for stopping over
like make sure they're in bed by 8:00
there's 20 bucks on the table for kibble
so please don't eat my baby with the
fact with the fact that they are
practically overseeing their own
oversight it is hardly surprising that
cable companies are basically monopolies
now a federal study found that 96
percent of the population had access to
two or fewer cable broadband providers
it's almost as if they've agreed to stay
out of each other's way like drug
cartels but hold on hold on oh that's
not fair that's not fair I mean if
hypothetically a cable company like
Comcast were planning to merge with a
company like let's say Time Warner it's
not like their CEO would sit down and
Mark out who had which turf right but in
video and in broadband we don't compete
with Time Warner you have to start with
that very fundamental point there in New
York we're in Philadelphia they're in LA
we're in San Francisco you can't buy a
Comcast in New York you can't buy a Time
Warner in Philadelphia so there's no
reduction in competition exactly you
can't reduce competition when nobody is
competing you could not be describing a
monopoly more clearly if you are wearing
a metal top hat while driving a metal
car after winning second prize in a
beauty contest
maybe it's because of their lack of
competition they get away with providing
such shitty service we pay more for our
internet service than almost anybody
else on earth and yet the download
speeds we get lag behind Estonia Estonia
a country where from the looks of it
they still worried about Shrek attacks
is it any wonder that in in a massive
recent customer satisfaction surveys
Comcast and Time Warner Cable came in
dead last and when you look at the
companies that were scored better than
them people were basically saying yes
Bank of America took my home yes Taco
Bell gave me diarrhea and sure GM tried
to kill me Time Warner and Comcast are
the worst
they are the new us
[Music]
I know I know
the cable companies will say oh they
support net neutrality protections or
they remain committed to the open
Internet or just the tip but let me
remind you
they also say that they'll be at your
house between 2:00 and 6:00 tomorrow
afternoon there's any part of you really
expect them to intern up and yet our
government looks set to end net
neutrality and let these companies run
hog wild and we're just going to let
them and you know why it all comes back
to this it seeks comment on ways to
construe additional language in section
706 and even suggests using section 230
B to broaden the scope of the
Commission's usurped authority oh my god
how are you still so dull and that's the
problem the cable companies have figured
out the great truth of America if you
want to do something evil put it inside
something boring Apple could put the
entire text of mine camp inside the
iTunes User Agreement and you just go
agree agree agree agree that's why
should not be talking about protecting
net neutrality they shouldn't even use
that phrase they should call it
preventing cable company factoring
because that is what it is and it might
actually compel people to want to do
something and the interesting thing here
is there might actually be something you
can still do the FCC will be taking
public comment for 120 days that's right
the FCC are literally inviting internet
comments at this address
and at this point and I can't believe
I'm about to do this I would like to
address the internet commenters out
there directly
good evening monsters this may be the
moment you've spent your whole life
straining for you have been out there
ferociously commenting on dance videos
of adorable three-year-olds say things
like every child could dance like this
little loser after one week of practice
or you've been polluting frozen's let it
go with comments like ice castle would
give her hypothermia and she dead in an
hour and I know you've done this one
commenting or video on this show say
this anchor don't suck your
presidents you're just friends with the
terrorists I don't think it's a
compliment but this is the moment you
were made for commenters like Rob Ralph
Macchio you've been honing your skills
waxing cars and painting fences well
guess what now it's time to do something
karate for once in your life we need you
to channel that anger that badly spelled
boil that you normally reserved for
unforgivable attacks on actresses you
seem to think I put on weight or
politicians that you disagree with or
functors of your ex-girlfriend getting
on with her life or non-white actors
being cast as fictional characters and
I'm talking to you Ron Paul fan 2016
one direction forever and I'm talking to
you one direction sucks balls we need
you to get out there and for once in
your lives
focus your indiscriminate range in a
useful direction cease your noggins my
lovely trolls
[Applause]